thanks for the introduction and thanks
for coming so as the title suggests i
will speak about some connection between
parameterize the complexity and clas
classic time and space complexity so for
the time case actually the materials are
mostly quite old from two thousand six
and two thousand seven the new thing is
this connection actually carries over to
to to space case or to space complexity
but in the case of space is quite easy
to show in fact but I I try to convince
you perhaps there might be in the space
version of exponential time hypothesis
and this could be useful to derive pipes
some space optimality of some space
algorithms okay so let's go back to the
so exponential term complex exponential
complexity and parametric complexity so
we have seen a lot of results in this
week showing there's a close connection
between two areas but if you go back to
to see the original motivation of these
two area you see some difference so in
the exponential complexity so algorithms
we want to find exponential time
algorithm or exact algorithm for NP hard
problems that can beat that can be
significantly faster than the brute
force search but we know that perhaps
for some problems there might be not so
much hope so the most famous conjecture
is this exponential time hypothesis so
there is no algorithm sewing set in time
to to the little o of n so using this we
have seen lots of tight lower bounds and
in a case of parameterize the complexity
the goal is to to isolate some
parameters in the problem instance and
design algorithm so that the exponential
type exponential behavior is confined in
those parameters so these are quite
different from find Evie so best
exponential time algorithms and here the
working hypothesis is for problem like k
creek there's no FPT algorithm there is
no algorithm solving k clicking time f
of k a polynomial of the size of the
graph no matter how bad this function f
is
so you see they're two different things
but in the in the beginning quite early
so people realize there's a connection
between these two areas so this result
approved by done in a fellow shows that
exponential time hypothesis in fact
implies w1 is different from FB t or
equivalently there's no FPT algorithm
solving click so this is the conduction
and there was some effort to prove the
converse and in fact it was a major open
problem but perhaps now people realize
this is extremely hard to prove when
strong evidence is this result by
general Chen and his co-authors so in th
in flight in fact implies and the
stronger as a statement that create
quickly cannot be decided in time f of k
a into the little of k so instead of in
a polynomial of n so if you can prove
that ETH is equivalent to FP t is not
equal to w1 then you prove that in case
you have an algorithm solving k click F
of K in to the little of K in fact you
can remove this little of K that seems
to be at least for me extremely
difficult so there's only one direction
for now but in fact there is an
equivalence between two statement one
flaw exponential complexity the other
from Parramatta rest complexity in fact
w1 is equal to F PT if and only if K
click the same problem can be solved in
time to to the letter O of K log and a
polynomial of n so that's an in fact an
equivalence instead of true to the
little o of ko so if you want to
understand this statement you just need
to look at this brutal force our in
solving k click which takes time into
the k plus some constant so into the k
is the time you need to enumerate ok
subset of the graph slightly rewrite
this term you get 2 to the K log in a
polynomial of n so this statement is to
say that you can in fact improve this
brute force algorithm and the key log
and in fact recent lens
of a binary encoding of a key element
subset so we have an equivalent
statement between parameterize the
complexity of exponential time
complexity so another important
equivalence is due to tire in the Judas
they show that ETH fails or Sri setter
hasn't several exponential time
algorithm if the normally if the
miniaturization of three set this is a
parameter eyes the problem i were
introduced in a few minutes this problem
is fixed parameter tractable but you
will see this is a rather artificial
problem but again i want to say that
there is an in fact and the equivalence
between exponential complexity and
parameter as the complexity
so one natural question if you are
interested in space complexity is there
anything similar in case of space so if
you look at the space complexity when
central problem is of course this st
conductivity so we are given a great
direct graph g a source node s and sink
node T you want to find whether there is
a path connecting going from s to T so
this is the standard standard in your
complete problem sewing space complexity
and due to a famous our origin by savage
we know how to solve it in space Big O
of log N squared it has been a major
open problem whether we can improve
these savages algorithm deciding st
connectivity instead of space big o of
log n square we want to find our
algorithm running in space little of
logging square i guess this is a open
problem for more than 40 years or prove
this is impossible so what i want to
convince your perhaps this is a space
analog of the exponential term
hypothesis so what is the parameterize
the version of this st calm so of course
we we need to introduce a small
parameter so we have an additional
parameter k instead besides graph g and
source s and sync t so we want to find a
part from s to T of lens at most K so
this is what I call kst calm so in
parramatta rise complexity as it has
been asked whether we can decide this
problem in space f of k plus log in or
big o of log in
remember that the problem is self if you
view this as a classic problem is
complete for NL so this statement in
fact asked whether in case of K being
extremely small can we solve ratings
lock determinist love space
okay if you look at the brute force
algorithm deciding kst com it runs in
space k log and plus a linear factor of
log n so ke logon is the space you need
to store our parts of landscape so the
next natural question is whether you can
improve this to obtain an algorithm with
space little K log and plus or login and
if so it's very easy to show that ksd
common factor in seeing parameterised
log space if you go back to savages
algorithm you see that the algorithm in
fact solve this problem in space log K
times log in
but it looks like an improvement to K
log in because you have log K instead of
K but it's clear that log k log n Times
log in is not really o K log in if you
fix k and let n tends to infinity you
see this goes to log and this is a
little ol log log in that's different so
savage sovereign is not really in an
improvement as we want in this question
but given savage the algorithm the next
thing is you ask whether que esta com
can be solved in Little Rock a log in
because the linear factor of log in so
this would be an improvement of Farage
darwin now we come to the space and
analogy of this eth or this equivalence
between parameterize time complexity
exeter and exponential time complexity
so first thing we can show you if you
can put kst come as a pair metallized
property in parramatta rise the log
space sewing it in space f of k + o log
n then in fact you can improve savages
theorem you put st calm in space little
over of log n squared so this would be
similar to the case of time you have K
log and indy time F of K for the N imply
three set in sub exponential time
and if you go a little bit further you
can prove in fact you can weaken this
assumption we only need ksd come in
space f f of k plus little locket log in
this assumption would already implies an
algorithm in improving service algorithm
again this is similar in a case of time
if you have Kayla okay clicking f of k
into little of k then already three
settings a baseborn a short time so what
about the equivalence remember we have
some equivalents in the time case here
we have this equivalence among three
statement so the first thing is kst come
in parramatta rise the log space the
second statement is a que esta com in
space little oh CLE login + o log n this
would be an improvement of this brutal
force algorithm remember we have a
brutal force our in storing a path of
length K log in which need space k log
in okay so this is the second stain the
statement is an improvement of savage
sovereign you put ksd coming these space
little lock a log and plus ER or login
so in fact all these three statement are
equivalent so this is an analogy of this
k clicking f of k and okay if and only
if this should be 0 1 so that's a typo k
clicking time to to the later oh k log
in a poly factor of n so so these are
the equivalence and the equivalency in
fact can be showed just by once right so
I want to show you the equivalence
between kst come in paralogs base and k
st coming this base little or k log n
plus a linear factor of log n so the
direction from right to right to left is
the simple observation little ke logon
can be bounded by f of k plus long and
choosing by choosing the appropriate
function f so this is 3 forward the
other direction in fact are you just
plug in this search
theorem with this assumed algorithm
solving kst come in space f of k + o log
n so in that case I know if I choose K
small enough so for instance I can
choose a parts of lens DD is an inverse
of F n log n if you're plugging this
value to K you see that I can solve find
a path of lens at most D in logarithmic
space what so imagine you fix k then if
K is a log and is sufficiently large
this is dominated by login for each k
you see is dominated by log in so you
only need to consider 4k fixed K a
sufficiently large number to dominate
this effect or senior
sorry little or suggest a function they
imagine this is the h h of something x
so when x goes to infinity it goes to so
later so it / x equals to 0 then you
plug in this function edge with k log in
and so now I go back to the second
direction so remember we can decide and
pass a final parts of lens at most D
being this value in logarithmic space
then I we modify savage salga rhythm
remembering savage sagar ism we do this
double squaring things so now we divide
each recursive step the path of length
at most K I into d sub parts of lens at
most ki plus one being ki over D so d is
this value and it's easy to see that
total space I need can be bounded in the
end little o of K log in so this is a
straightforward modification of savage
sovereign so there is a simple proof
showing this equivalence between sub
exponent a sub linear space or parameter
is space but in the remaining part of
the talk I want to unify all these
things these three things the first
thing is FP t equals w1 if and only if
cake lately is decidable in time to to
the little o ke logon poly in the second
thing is ETH fails if and only if the
miniaturization of cake lick is fixed
parameter tractable the last thing is
the equivalence I show you in the
previous slide in the case of space for
kst com so I want to show you there is
an unifying framework to to show these
equipments these three equipments so
this is what we call the miniaturization
isomorphism the isomorphism between
parameterize complexity and the classic
complexity so to understand this we need
a little bit more notions so we're all
familiar with Parramatta lies the
complexity so here we are given a
problem and besides the problem instance
we need to either identify a parameter
of this instance now for the exponential
complexity we need is what we call is
called a size measure so formal a pair
motorization and size measure are the
same thing they are just two functions
mapping a probing instance to a small
number to a number
not necessarily small so far for our
purpose we need both of them took be
computed computable in log rhythmic
space so remember the parameter is
supposed to be much smaller than the
problem instance so couple of X is the
parameter of X which is small far
smaller than the length of X and in the
case of the size measure it always
represent the lens of a limpiar witness
of X so let me show you some examples so
4k click the standard parameterization
is just the size of the click click it's
ok I want to fight and you can take the
size measure as K times log n n is the
number of vertices in the input graph so
this would be the lens of a description
of a click or K element subset in the
case of KS decom the parameter is ok
again the size measure you can again
take K log n so this would be a binary
string describing a passive landscape
for three sets there's no natural small
parameters so for our purpose we only
need the size measure so we can take the
number of variables as the size measure
of us reason a formula or the number of
clauses as the size measure of this
formula c 3 c NM so in the case of
chapter ability so remember impairment
rest complexity the chapter ability is
fixed parameter tractability we are
looking for our is moose running time f
of the parameter a polynomial of the
import lens the intractability so mostly
we are interested only interested in pro
burning XP so those problem deciding
time x to the f of the parameter so for
classic case in the time case we have
this sub exponential time we are looking
for algorithm with running time to to
the size measure sighs measure of the
input times a polynomial of the
importance and the for exp this would be
2 to the all of the size measure times
polynomial of the input lens so for the
case of exp so exponential time this
would be the running time of all
enumerated all NP witness of the input X
so this is the meaning of exponential
time for sub exponential time of course
we want to avoid such an enumeration we
want to do some exponential algorithms
so as we are looking for complexity
theory we also need a kind of reduction
so I won't be giving you the definition
of the reductions but just put in the
name on the slide so in case of
parramatta rise to complexity we have a
PT reduction and the FP tetouan
reduction and in case of classic
exponential complexity we have this
so-called self reduction sub exponential
reduction family reduction or self
tooling reduction so what is important
for us is fpg and I xperia closer and
all those know fpt tooling reductions
and sub XP and XP are closed and the
soft reductions
so the well-known specification lamb
binding factor is a soft reduction from
3sat with size measure the number of
variables to three set the same problem
with stress measure the number of
clauses so this is the self reduction
the specification lemma stated as a surf
reduction now we come to the space
complexity so in parramatta lies the
complexity we have paralogs space so a
problem cukup is in peril of space means
that i have an an hour is moose running
time f of the parameter plus all log x +
4 intractability we always look at
problems with running space f of the
parameter x log X so one is the addition
the other is the multiple multiplication
of these two terms so we in the case of
classic complexity we have sub linear
space source problem can be decided in
space little all of the size measure
plus log X we have also linear space as
the intractable problem with running
space all of the size measure + 0 of log
X and the linear space is clearly those
consists of those problems that can be
solved by storing or NP witness of X
because you remember mu of X or the size
measure of X is the length of NP witness
so you go through all the impossible and
key witness so this new linear space and
sub linear spacer is of course you try
to avoid storing those NP witnesses so
here again we have reductions preserving
those checked abilities so I
in case of parramatta lies complexity we
have what we call PR reduction or
Parramatta rise the log space reduction
in classic complexity we have this sub
linear reduction family so as our notion
of reductions
yes I I don't have much time so now I
introduce this miniaturization mapping
between these two theories this would be
the mapping sending Parramatta problem
from classic complexity to Parramatta
rest complexing so imagine you have a
problem Q together with a size measure
new so you define the following
Parramatta lies the problem as we call
it meaning of the Q new so the input
would be an instance prob'ly instance X
so you need an additional import a
natural number in unary assuming this
number M is greater or equal to the
length of X the parameter would be the
run-up of this new of x over log in and
the question is the same you want to
decide whether X is a nice instance so
if you see this problem for the first
time it looks completely artificial but
again this it's hard to explain but what
is important is the following it really
works so we have this isomorphism in the
time case so remember in parramatta rise
to complexity we look at those probing
XP and we want to know which of them
really fixed parameter tractable and in
the case of exponential complexity we
want to see which problem is can be
solved in sub baseball national time so
the isomorphism first carries every
problem in subjects for national time to
a problem in fixed earning fpt actually
these goes both ways so if you have a
problem q new so this problem is in sub
exp if and only if it's miniaturization
is fixed parameter tractable and that
the second is if you have a problem in
exp it really goes to through this
miniaturization to a pro kneeing XP and
what is more important at least for me
is this isomorphism preserving
reductions so if you have two problems q
1 u 1 and Q 2 new to you know there is a
reduction from q2 new to to kill when
you too then there is a reduction from
the miniaturization of the second
problem to the miniaturizer
of the first problem and the other
direction also holds this gives you the
isomorphism which preserve reductions
hope you can see from this picture I we
can use this miniaturization isomorphism
mapping everything faithfully to to the
parameter eyes the complexity so
everything in exponential complexity to
expo parameterize the complexity but if
you speak about isomorphism of course
you have to guarantee the other
direction so you would ask whether every
problem XP would be in a pre-image front
of an the property in exp by this
miniaturization mapping of course this
cannot be true because miniaturized the
problem has a very special form there
are lots of problems XP has no have no
such form but we can actually show that
if you have a problem in XP a parramatta
lies the problem in slice wise
polynomial time you can really find a
pretty image of the problem in the
following sense you can find a problem
in exponential time which under this
magnetization you get a mini queue of
this problem which is a pity equivalent
to the original problem p kappa stated
formula so you start from our p kappa
from XP then you can construct the
problem q using exponential company XP
such that p kappa is f bt equivalent to
the miniaturization of cube so this
shows that although this isomorphism is
not in a strict sense an isomorphism but
if you understand problem there's
problems are closed and the reductions
it really gives you an isomorphism
between these two theories so everything
in XP is mapped to XP and everything XP
can be traced back to to exp if you look
at this proof as you can imagine because
it's a very general statement the
problem we construct here is a highly
artificial but it turns out which also
involves some camana torial argument
if you look at this concrete prominent k
clip so take this que esta parameter is
fpt equivalent to the miniaturization of
K click taking k log and Esther sighs
measure so this statement shows that if
you take pic lick you understand k click
SL classic problem with size mejor que
log in using this magnetization it gives
you precisely the parameterize the key
click problem and there's a simple
consequences the consequence sort of
previous isomorphism we can conclude
immediately k click is fpt if and only
if k click is in service born as your
time that's the equivalence now we go to
that space complexity here we have this
linear space and sub linear space and we
have Parramatta lies a lot of space and
slice wise log space again this
isomorphism just translate everything
from linear space to slice slice space
and everything sub linear space to
parameterize the space so this is
statement and also this isomorphism
preserve reductions this gives you the
isomorphism carry everything exactly in
England your space to to to slice wise
linear space in param Angeles space
complexity again we have this subjective
subjectivity so if you start with a
problem Excel you can find on pre image
by this miniaturization mapping so again
we can show so this is the the thing we
prove quite easily but now can be stated
and as a general can be on the students
a special case of this general
phenomenon que esta com taking KS the
parameter is pure equivalent to the
miniaturization of KS become taking ke
logon as the size measure the
consequences this equivalence
so that tells you miniaturize the
miniaturization is not only isomorphism
between time complexity it's also an
isomorphism between space complexity so
to conclude my talk I want to show you
an application so far we don't have
really we don't really have many
application so this is one of them so we
know there are lots of tight bound under
ETH so what about this st come now doing
these space little log n square so here
is an application from of database or
logic so in this question we are given a
database a imagine this is a graph and
we are given a boolean conjecture query
5 with D variables this is a simple
first order sentence using only d
variables but you can reuse them you are
only allowed to use its substantial
quantifiers and that the parameter is
fine we want to decide whether a is a
model of file this craft satisfy this
formula or this database satisfy this
boolean conjunctive query so we can show
this problem can be solved in this space
or log by log a not very easy but no so
not very difficult and assume st come is
not in this space little ol log n
squared then there is no algorithm
improving this so there is no algorithm
using space f of fine no matter how bad
f is plus little ol log x times log a
the size of the database so this tells
you using this st come not so savage
algorithm cannot be improved we can
really derive the optimality of certain
certain algorithms that concludes my
talk thank you
whether any questions
thanks again